[Music]
Magnus welcome back to Croatia glad to
see you here and you wrote in your
Instagram that it's one of your favorite
cities what is special about Zagreb uh I
seem to do very well when I play here
um but in general I like cities where
um well especially during summer where
you can walk around exercise outside you
know beautiful old buildings good
restaurants and a general you know good
holiday Vibe yeah that's great and I was
wondering how many do you know how many
times have you won tournaments on
granchester
do you have any record
uh no uh I don't remember how many
tournaments I've won I have a feeling
that in terms of classical probably I
haven't won that many and in terms of
rapid and Blitz I think I've won most of
the tournaments that I've played wow but
we can ask tarji normally he has all the
statistics
and one more question is you know
exactly one year ago you made this very
special announcement for the whole Chess
World which of course has its impact the
history of Chess you said that you're
not going to defend your title anymore
so one year has passed and my question
is let's say how do you feel about it
now after one year and what impact has
it had on your own life and on your
chest and motivation
I would say
um the
that it feels pretty similar as to what
it did last year and also uh before that
that I'd sort of mentally
um checked out of the world championship
and
it feels good not to have to to worry
about it in terms of my motivation I
think now for for a number of years the
motivation has come and gone a little
bit and you can see that in some of the
tournaments that I I play
that sometimes
um you can sense that it's really really
important to me is other other times
tomorrow like yeah we'll see how it goes
and and then the the results often often
show that so I I think like you know
recently I haven't played so well but
I've had bad stretches
before and I'm definitely motivated now
to to strike back in this one yeah and
also you we could see you in the list of
the tournament of World Cup in Baku and
I think it's probably the only event
you've never won and do you have any
special motivations for this event as
well
so I I originally had other plans during
the times of the World Cup then they
didn't happen
um and it was actually during Norway
chess that I
that I thought thought about the
possibility of playing the World Cup at
all
um
and throughout the tournament there I
felt like I wasn't doing so well so I
was thinking that yeah it would be good
to get a chance to play some classical
chess again just to prove that I'm not
not as bad as I was as I was sharing
there yeah I mean we're looking forward
for sure for the classical event too and
if I ask you like
what is the most memorable GCT event
which comes first to your mind
I think
[Music]
there there are there are a few uh
classical definitely Zagreb 29 2019 it
was uh yeah it was just a good vibe
overall and one of my very best
classical results
uh apart from that
uh I would say
I remember
2017 very well and um also Kolkata 2019
was was a lot of fun yeah also I
remember in Kolkata there were many many
people come in lots of fans and actually
we also witnessed the same here in
Zagreb and I just wanted to tell you
that there was one girl last year chess
fan who came here and she asked you for
autograph on her shoulder and next day
she has made tattoo from your with your
signature and I just wonder wondered
what do you think about it and if there
is any person in this world you would
like to have tattoo signature
on your body
no I don't have any tattoos currently
and I don't have any plans of it but I
think as for other people if you're
going to get a tattoo I think my
signature is not the worst wait wait to
deface your your body yep so we'll see
what's happening this year and actually
expecting lots of people coming and you
are here from yesterday did somebody
catch you already for your signatures
for you know selfies like how do you
feel
do yourself yeah I um
I I I I I I do you know when I'm walking
around I do gets caught up by by chess
fans so
once in a while and
um most of the time it's their um really
nice and it's uh it's fine yeah okay all
the best of luck for in the
in this and in the others as well thank
you so much thank you
[Music]